So Shiny for Python,
if you're not already
familiar with Shiny,
Shiny is a framework
for building interactive
web applications.
So it's been almost
10 years to the date
that we've had Shiny in R,
but over the past year or so.
We've been working on
essentially porting
that foundation over to Python
so that Python users can
have a similar, very
approachable framework
for building interactive web
applications without needing
to already know HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
So even though we try to
make this approachable,
we still sort of build
this on a foundation that's
very flexible and scalable.
So these are kind of
built on foundations
that allow you to build out
your own custom components,
sort extend some of
the reactivity concepts
to implement your own sort
of modular functionalities.
And also the sort of reactive
framework that powers
all of this.
One of the reasons
why it's so nice
is it kind of allows you to
declare what should happen,
and then Shiny
handles the details
of what actual
computations to execute
when they need to be executed.
So it kind of allows you to
write this expressive reactive
code without needing to handle
every specific case of when
this changes, then also
update this other thing.
So for a very sort of
hello world example,
you can see it here
running in the browser.
And this is how you would start
programming a very basic Shiny
application.
So you can see I'm
importing from Shiny.
There's a UI package
inside of Shiny.
So this is how you'll
actually create or define
where things should go in
the actual user interface
of the Shiny application.
There's also a
rendering package.
And this is sort of
utilities for rendering
things like matplotlib plots
or various different types
of Python output into
actual stuff that
can go into a user interface.
And then every
Shiny application is
going to want this capital
A, App, to actually bring
the two main pieces of
the Shiny app together.
That being the user interface
here from lines 3 to 6.
This is the definition of what
you see on the right here,
as well as the server
logic, which kind of
takes Python objects and
renders them into things that
can go into the user interface.
So in this particular
basic example,
I have created
this user interface
by first creating sort
of a page container.
So we have several different
variants on different types
of pages that you can create.
Page fluid in a lot of
cases is it's pretty basic,
but covers most use cases
for just starting a new user
interface.
And then inside of there, I
will put a slider component,
and give this an
ID of lowercase N.
And then this is a label
that should appear just
above the slider.
So I'm going to put a
capital N for a label.
Define the minimum and the
maximum for the slider,
and then a starting
value for that slider.
And the way that
Shiny works is you,
basically in this
user interface,
you give every kind of user
interface component an ID,
and then you can
reference whatever
the current value of that
input is on the server
by saying input.n.
And then you kind
of read that value
by calling it like a function.
So if I had several
different input components
with different IDs
I would, of course,
change the name
here after the dots,
and then call it like a
function to basically read
whatever the current value is.
And you might have noticed
in this server definition
when you define this
server function,
it takes three arguments.
The input values that are coming
in from this user interface.
An output argument,
and we're going
to use this output object
to basically hook up values
that we create on the server
up with the user interface.
And then also a
session, which we're not
going to get into
here, but this can
allow you to do things specific
to a specific user's session
experience.
So with this server
definition, I'm
going to create an
output that's going
to be connected to this
output text_verbatim
with an ID of text.
And with every output,
when you first create it,
you're going to want to then
provide a rendering decorator.
So here @render.text
basically means
I want to define
a function that's
going to return a string,
that I can just put verbatim
into this whatever UI component
I'm hooking up this return
value to.
And this part right here,
the actual name of this
function that I'm providing
to the render text
and the output
decorator is going
to define the output
ID essentially
that should match this
sort of UI container
that I want to hook
up this value to.
Now that I've kind of declared
that there's an output that I
want to render as text
with an ID of text or txt,
and provide it inside of--
and provide this sort
of function expression
that reads a reactive
value, this input.n,
by declaring it
this way, then Shiny
knows basically whenever
this inputs and changes
I will re-execute this
function, and basically
create a new return value
for this text verbatim here.
So that's a long way
of saying like whenever
I change this slider value
here, this gray text box below
is going to update to be 2 times
whatever the value this slider
is.
A neat thing about this
that I don't really
want to steal my colleague
Winston's thunder too
much on is the fact that this
is all running in the browser.
So we've kind of
built this foundation
for allowing you to take
simple Shiny applications
and run them purely in the
browser without a Python
process running
in the background.
So this is actually
statically hosted on Netlify
through GitHub pages.
And I have a running
Shiny application
here that I can actually modify
the source code of this Shiny
application and say I want maybe
five times the current value
of this slider.
Restart, it's going to start
with an initial value of 40
here.
And now I've got 5
times 40 in the output.
So that's just kind
of a neat side note
that you'll notice as I'm kind
of going through more examples.
Some of these will just
run purely in the browser.
But you can learn more
about that in another video.
Currently, I don't know if this
link will change at any point.
I would imagine that
it will eventually
have the company's branding and
everything in the link name.
But for now, yes,
pyshiny.netlify.app
is the best place to go to.
And then there's
some getting started
stuff, some information on
how to install information
about how to deploy to
our different professional
products, going into
some concepts in depth,
and then there's a link
here to examples that
is kind of a different site with
all sorts of different examples
that are running in the browser.
[MUSIC PLAYING]